RYAN GERMICK: Thank you
all for coming or
tuning in on the internet.
RICH MOORE: Hello, internet.
RYAN GERMICK: You don't want
to know what this man does
with the internet.
Mr.--
RICH MOORE: The-- you're--
RYAN GERMICK: What?
Go ahead.
RICH MOORE: No, go ahead.
RYAN GERMICK: No, your turn.
You're the star.
RICH MOORE: You don't
want to know
what I do on the internet.
That's true.
RYAN GERMICK: OK.
This is Mr. Rich Moore.
Give it up.
RICH MOORE: Thank you.
RYAN GERMICK: He's visiting
us from--
RICH MOORE: Whoa.
Wait a minute.
Google's chair is
all-- this is--
RYAN GERMICK: It's to
add to the drama.
We want to care about the
characters on the stage, so
you put them in some danger.
RICH MOORE: We do.
We do.
You kind of created a little
conflict here.
And you're trying to see
what I'll do, how
I'll adjust to it.
RYAN GERMICK: My goal is to
create as much conflict--
RICH MOORE: Checkmate.
RYAN GERMICK: Oh.
Well, I have the same thing.
I think they just have one
nail or something.
It's to fold up.
So it folds up.
RICH MOORE: You guys have a
slide here in your lobby.
RYAN GERMICK: We have
a slide, yeah.
RICH MOORE: That's
pretty cool.
RYAN GERMICK: It goes
into the lobby.
Correct me if I'm wrong.
I think the entrance to the
slide is on a floor that you
can't go on unless you have,
like, a special badge.
RICH MOORE: Well, where's
it's the fun in that?
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah, that's
what I want to know.
RICH MOORE: Why would they--
it's like the Winchester
Mystery House or something.
RYAN GERMICK: There's also, in
building 43, there's a bunch
of doors that open
into nothing.
It's really spooky.
What are we here for?
RICH MOORE: I don't know.
I came for the slide, and
now I'm finding out that
I can't ride it.
RYAN GERMICK: We'll
get you in.
RICH MOORE: Do you have
a fireman's pole?
RYAN GERMICK: No.
Like the Ghostbuster house?
AUDIENCE: New York has one.
RYAN GERMICK: New
York has one?
RICH MOORE: Oh, OK.
Well, good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RYAN GERMICK: Oh, of course.
What else do you want to know?
RICH MOORE: Do you have one of
those balls where you put your
hands on it, and the plasma
makes your hair stick up?
RYAN GERMICK: Oh, like a Tesla
coil kind of thing?
Probably.
I would imagine.
RICH MOORE: You got
one of those?
RYAN GERMICK: Nerd fail.
RICH MOORE: Do you have
a Jacob's Ladder?
RYAN GERMICK: Is that like a--
RICH MOORE: No?
Gotcha.
Well, it's really cool here.
It's an amazing place.
It's my first time
coming to Google.
RYAN GERMICK: We're really
happy to have you.
RICH MOORE: Well, thank you.
RYAN GERMICK: You all know
this man is a director of
Disney's new film,
"Wreck-It Ralph."
RICH MOORE: Thank you.
RYAN GERMICK: But that's
just the tip of
the iceberg for you.
RICH MOORE: The tip of the
animation iceberg.
RYAN GERMICK: You've done
so many things.
I want to go over some of those
things as we start.
I have this clicker, and
I'm gonna go first.
RICH MOORE: Whoa, this
thing just changed.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah,
it changed.
RICH MOORE: Oh, you did it.
OK.
RYAN GERMICK: I did it.
So you are a college graduate.
RICH MOORE: I did go
to a college, yes.
RYAN GERMICK: Did
you graduate?
RICH MOORE: I graduated
from a college
with a degree in cartoons.
RYAN GERMICK: Fantastic.
RICH MOORE: Yeah.
Which makes me the dumbest
person in this room.
RYAN GERMICK: Well, college
was less expensive.
RICH MOORE: No math.
RYAN GERMICK: I also
went to art school.
RICH MOORE: Yeah?
Which one?
RYAN GERMICK: I went to
Parsons in New York.
RICH MOORE: That's nice.
RYAN GERMICK: If they had
a cartoon program, I
would have done it.
But they didn't,
so I couldn't.
RICH MOORE: I love Parsons
in New York.
That's great.
RYAN GERMICK: But I also don't
know a thing about math.
I have no idea.
RICH MOORE: Good.
RYAN GERMICK: It'll be
just the three of us.
RICH MOORE: We've got all these
guys to ask, you know?
RYAN GERMICK: And your school
was pretty impressive.
A lot of animators come
out of there.
RICH MOORE: Yes.
RYAN GERMICK: Started
by Mr. Walt Disney.
RICH MOORE: Mr. Walt Disney.
Walt Elias Disney.
RYAN GERMICK: When you work for
a Disney movie, do they
just forgive your
student loans?
Is that how they pay you?
RICH MOORE: No, actually,
they know where you are.
And they were on my
back every day.
It was just, the email,
every day.
Just a reminder.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
Interest.
It changed again.
Back here.
So I did a little research
on the internet.
And you had some pretty amazing
people in your class
back at CalArts.
Do you want to identify some
of the folks back here?
RICH MOORE: Well, let's see.
That would be me in the
yellow shirt, or that
kind of orange shirt.
RYAN GERMICK: Basketball
player.
The athlete of the group.
RICH MOORE: Yeah, see,
look at that.
No, that's Steve Markowski
standing next to me, and I
thin he was holding
the basketball.
That's Tony Fucile
on the right hand
side, an amazing animator.
RYAN GERMICK: All these people
are wicked accomplished.
RICH MOORE: Yeah.
And we have Andrew Stanton
in the black shirt, in
the front row there.
RYAN GERMICK: Director
of "Wall-E."
RICH MOORE: Director of "Wall-E"
and "Finding Nemo."
We have right behind him
Jeff Pidgeon, who is a
story artist at Pixar.
RYAN GERMICK: This is his
picture, actually.
I stole it from his--
RICH MOORE: Really, from Jeff?
He's a good guy, you know,
to share it with.
Thank you, Jeff.
That's a nice picture.
And right next to Jeff in the
Hawaiian shirt, that's Jim
Reardon, co-writer of "Wall-E"
and co-writer of "Wreck-It
Ralph." And Jim and I worked on
"The Simpsons" together for
a long time.
And right in front of Jim, in
the pink blouse, is Brenda
Chapman, the director of
"Brave." So a lot of good
people in that class.
RYAN GERMICK: A lot
of good people.
That's exciting.
RICH MOORE: Good folks.
Solid.
Salt of the earth types.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
Just good Midwesterners?
RICH MOORE: Yeah.
RYAN GERMICK: What did you
learn in art school?
You didn't learn math.
We know that.
RICH MOORE: What did I
learn in art school?
Well, we learned from each
other, really, in art school.
As you see, our class was a
little bit bigger than this.
This is not everyone
in our class.
But we were like a
little family.
There were about 25 of
us in our class.
And we really learned how to
collaborate with one another
very, very well.
At CalArts, then as it is now,
the main goal is to produce a
student film at the end
of the school year.
And it was always our opinion of
our class, like the better
our entire class's selection
of films were, the
better the show was.
No one was ever in it
just for themselves.
We really helped each other
a lot with our films.
And that wasn't always the way
in other classes at CalArts.
And I can remember Brenda was
working on a movie, a student
film about an old lady who'd
been forgotten on her
birthday, and was having some
troubles with the story.
So even though it was not
something that the rest of us
had any interest in-- doing
that type of film was very
serious, it wasn't very
funny at all--
everyone kind of put aside our
own tastes and really jumped
in to help Brenda
with her film.
And that's just the
way we were.
And we would always kind
of check on each
other and go around.
We really enjoyed each other's
company, and we really kind of
honed the art of kind of being
there for one another and
collaborating and helping each
other make each other's films,
or whatever the project was,
better than it could be with
just the one person
working on it.
RYAN GERMICK: It's like the
Wu Tang of animation.
RICH MOORE: That's right.
Yeah.
Pretty much.
We were year 10 at CalArts of
the character animation
department.
And this was also kind of the
way that year one was like,
and that was guys like Brad Bird
and Joe Ranft and John
Musker, John Lasseter.
This was kind of a tradition
and a way of collaborating
that was kind of born
earlier at CalArts.
And really, I think when John
and Andrew and Pete Docter and
all these guys from that
school begin to kind of
creatively percolate at Pixar,
what they talk about the
process at Pixar, you hear
about that a lot, and the
brain trust, and just that kind
of collaborative effort
that goes into all their movies,
is really, I think, a
principle that was born kind
of from that college, from
those classrooms at CalArts.
So I really look back at those
days, like day one, as being
just the beginning of a journey
into a wonderful kind
of medium, and mindset that's
just served everyone who's
been a part of it so well
in their careers
and in their lives.
RYAN GERMICK: So another project
that after you got out
of school that you started on
was Mighty Mouse-- the "New
Adventures of Mighty Mouse."
That was another hugely
collaborative pool of genius.
RICH MOORE: Yeah.
There was a lot of great people
working on that show.
And you have to remember that
this was the summer of 1987.
I'm sure a lot of these people
weren't born at that time, or
were very young.
You, little guy, I'm sure
you weren't around.
And the state of animation was
not good in those days.
RYAN GERMICK: He-Man?
RICH MOORE: It was-- yeah.
RYAN GERMICK: A lot
of cheap stuff.
RICH MOORE: It was a lot of
Saturday morning cartoons and
afternoon half hours that were
basically commercials for
cereals and for toys.
So it was not as we
know it today.
So none of us graduating at that
time were really going
into this business for
the money or the
prestige or the fame.
We didn't know what we were kind
of stepping into, just
that we loved the medium.
So to graduate and then be able
to step into a project
like Mighty Mouse, that was
spearheaded by Ralph Bakshi,
who was an absolute hero of mine
for the different kinds
of things that he tried to make,
or that he did make when
I was a young person--
to be working with Ralph as a
first job was the best first
job a young animator could have
at that time, because
Ralph's a maverick.
He's a bigger than life type of
guy who really made a name
for himself in animation and
did some great stuff.
And to see him in action,
I mean, he's loud,
kind of just big.
It's like Jackie Gleason and
Fred Flintstone smushed
together into one
weird person.
A lot of people here don't
know who either of those
people are.
But it means a big loud guy.
RYAN GERMICK: Who lives
with dinosaurs.
RICH MOORE: With dinosaurs.
He was a great man to work
with, and a mentor to me,
because you would look at him
and say like, wow, if Ralph
could make it in this
business, I can too!
He was a real artist, and a
visionary, and a wonderful
person to work for.
And on that crew were people
like myself, and Jim, Andrew,
Jeff, John Kricfalusi was
a major contributor.
RYAN GERMICK: Creator
of "Ren and Stimpy."
RICH MOORE: Creator of "Ren and
Stimpy." Tom Minton who's
a really well known animation
writer, wrote for things like
"Pinky and the Brain." Bruce
Timm, who kind of rebooted and
revamped Batman into the
animated "Adventures of
Batman." And just
a ton of others.
Eddie Fitzgerald.
I mean, I could go down.
RYAN GERMICK: It's an
amazing pedigree.
RICH MOORE: It was an amazing,
amazing group of people to be
working with, who really
loved animation.
We were not there to
sell a product.
We were not there to sell
a cereal or a toy.
We were there to tell good
stories, funny stories, and
make entertainment.
And we were very lucky as
graduating artists out of
CalArts to kind of land in that
position at that time.
RYAN GERMICK: So you did a bunch
of other stuff as well.
But in the interest of
eventually talking about
"Wreck-It Ralph." there's a few
other projects I want to
hear your thoughts on.
So you were a huge contributor
to these guys.
RICH MOORE: Well, yeah.
About a year after working for
Ralph, another friend in the
business said, you've got to
check it out, because the
Tracey Ullman shorts, "The
Simpsons" shorts that they did
for TV, they're going to make
a series out of it.
They're hiring people
right now.
And they've got some storyboard
positions open.
I know you like it.
You should check it out.
Because I love Matt Groening.
I loved "Life In Hell," and
just all his comics.
And I loved Jim Brooks.
From a young age, I liked
"Taxi," and "Mary Tyler Moore
Show," and his movies
that he did.
And it was like, wow, they're
going to do a primetime
animated show?
And a lot of people thought,
like, oh, well, I give it two
episodes and it bombs.
RYAN GERMICK: 27 seasons
later, or whatever--
RICH MOORE: Yeah.
So that was the summer
of 1989.
And I started as a storyboard
artist.
And it was a very, very small
crew of people, again, who
were there because they loved
animation, and they believed
in this project.
And along the way, to just make
the story short, I was
promoted to be a director after
doing a few storyboards
on that show, because the
producers felt that I, out of
a lot of the people there, got
the humor and understood what
the show was about.
RYAN GERMICK: And some of the
greatest episodes, like the
first Halloween episode.
RICH MOORE: Yes.
Well, that particular story.
The first Halloween episode
was divided up between the
three directors at the time--
that was myself and David
Silverman and Les Archer.
We each took an act.
And I did this act.
RYAN GERMICK: How to
[INAUDIBLE] humans.
RICH MOORE: Yeah.
Which was so much fun, and I
mean, I loved designing the
characters, and it was a chance
to kind of do something
very kind of a pulpy
'50s schlocky
horror type movie thing.
So it was great to
be a part of.
And it's not seldom in your
life, or in my life, at least,
that you have a feeling in the
moment when it's happening
that you kind of get it.
Like, you get what's going on.
And I remember when I first
started directing on The
Simpsons, that reading the
scripts that we were producing
and working with that this was
really what I got into the
business for.
It made sense, like, well, this
is what I wanted to do.
And now I have this opportunity
to do it.
And this could be great.
This is as good as like, a Jay
Ward cartoon or something.
That this really could
be something.
And I had this feeling of I
would not be able to live with
myself if I do not give every
bit of my heart and soul for
this show, because I wouldn't
want to think, like, what if
I'd worked harder?
Could "The Simpsons" have
been something?
There was just this moment of
dedicating myself to the
thing, of like, I believe in
this material so much that I
will do whatever it takes to
deliver what I think is the
end result that it deserves.
RYAN GERMICK: What did that
mean in real life?
Like, did that mean you pulled
all-nighters, or you--
RICH MOORE: I mean, it's funny,
because I was just
talking with Amy, who came
in with me today.
I would say between 1990 and
1992, that's a big period of
time that I don't remember a lot
of stuff other than being
in those studios working
on those shows.
Like, who was president, or
current events, or what shows
were on, or what movies were out
was just out the window.
RYAN GERMICK: "Terminator
2" was decent.
RICH MOORE: And I resent "The
Simpsons" for robbing me of
that experience.
But it was at least a year and
a half or two years of seven
days a week, 12 to 18 hour days
for a year, year and a
half straight of producing
those episodes.
No one was telling
me to do it.
It was coming from me.
I was demanding myself to be
there and just make it the
best it could be, because we
were doing it with a really
tiny crew, too.
I mean, a fraction of
the people that
work on the show now.
I was doing the job of what they
would now divide between
five people.
And the other directors were
doing the same thing, too.
It wasn't just me.
It was that very small crew was
like, killing themselves,
because they really, really
believed in it.
RYAN GERMICK: So that
wasn't your only
project with Matt Groening.
RICH MOORE: No.
RYAN GERMICK: And so it's
something that has a lot of
love at Google.
RICH MOORE: Would
be this thing.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
"Futurama."
RICH MOORE: "Futurama."
RYAN GERMICK: So talk a little
bit about going from a
scrappy, upstart, small team
to like, kind of the second
version of a kind
of vision here.
Like, how did that work out?
RICH MOORE: It worked
out that--
well, I was on the Simpsons for
the first five seasons,
and then I worked on another
show with Gracie Films, who
produces "The Simpsons," called
"The Critic." And we
did two seasons of that.
And after that was finished--
see, Matt, even from season two
of "Simpsons," always had
the idea for "Futurama." I
remember one afternoon, he
took David, Wes and I--
the other directors--
out to lunch, and kind of
pitched through this idea for
"Futurama."
And we were like, that sounds
really cool, Matt.
Are we going to work on that?
Yeah, I'm on it!
When do we start?
Oh, I just have to kind of
write some things down.
And then we'll get
around to it.
But I'm working on it.
And then in Matt style, he's
got so much stuff going on
with "The Simpsons," it was
just such a big beast that
took his time.
It wasn't another seven years
or six years until I heard
from him again.
And I was now working at another
studio called Rough
Draft that was founded
by another
CalArts grad, Gregg Vanzo.
And I was a partner in that
studio, and Greg was
associated with the
Simpsons also.
And Matt came to us and said,
OK, I'm doing this science
fiction show.
And I want you guys
to work on it.
And it was a pretty scrappy
production.
It's not like things became
kind of fat and benign.
It was still lean and mean.
Because at that point, "The
Simpsons" was still kind of
considered like, well,
that's an anomaly.
"King of the Hill" was kind of
recreating that success.
And "Family Guy" was kind of
happening at the same time as
"Futurama." So Fox was really
kind of banking.
It wasn't a done deal.
It was like, well, what
can you guys do?
And one thing that Gregg and I
said to Matt about "Futurama"
was, look, if it's going to be
a science fiction show, the
quality of the animation has
to be higher than "The
Simpsons." We can't do like we
would do on the Halloween
shows, where we would try to
kind of animate cool looking
stuff, and it was
a little clunky.
We really wanted it
to look nice, but
also in Matt's style.
And that was always Matt's
thing, was, well, don't make
it too nice.
I don't want to be shiny.
I want it to look like
someone drew it.
So it was at that point that
Gregg and his brother Scott
Vanzo, who was the head of
technology at Rough Draft,
they kind of cracked and they
wrote this program that could
take computer animation and
render it with the black line
around it where it looked
like it was like toon
shaded type of stuff.
And today that means nothing,
but this was in 1989--
or no, 1997, I'm sorry.
Big difference.
So before that, you had stuff
like, what was that movie,
"Titan AE," that Fox did?
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah, like
particle animated, like fluid
dynamic stuff that's
really weird.
RICH MOORE: Well, it was like,
all the vehicles looked like
these beautiful, rendered shiny
ships, and then with 2D
animation flopped
on top of it.
And it didn't marry together.
And it made the world
unbelievable.
RYAN GERMICK: Which is maybe
a good transition into your
latest picture.
This is a Spanish film,
it's a foreign film.
RICH MOORE: I wanted to work
in Spanish, you know?
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
RICH MOORE: I'm from Southern
California.
And I have a deep love for
our southern neighbors.
RYAN GERMICK: Sure, sure.
So this is totally goes into
the realm of computer
generated 3D.
Although before "Wreck-It
Ralph," there's a really
beautiful short film
that seems to be--
RICH MOORE: "Paperman." Yeah.
RYAN GERMICK: That's really
terrific, and plays around
with the 2D/3D--
RICH MOORE: Well, yeah.
It's, again, taking that concept
that we were talking
about with "Futurama,"
of how to kind of
marry 2D and 3D together.
Because at Disney, where this
was produced and where
"Paperman" is produced, where I
work, it's unlike any other
animation studio today, because
we have a group of
traditional 2D artists and
animators that are the best in
the world at what they do.
So a lot of credit goes to
John Kahrs, who created
"Paperman" and directed it,
because he wanted to try and
create something using digital
animation, but then also
merging it with the hand drawn
art in a way that's different
from what you've seen before.
And I think it's really a
beautiful, really successful--
RYAN GERMICK: So even if you go
to the theater just to see
that and leave before "Wreck-It
Ralph" starts,
that's probably--
RICH MOORE: Hey!
Hey!
RYAN GERMICK: But I'm saying,
that's the added value.
RICH MOORE: But the only thing,
it's black and white.
RYAN GERMICK: Well, there's
spot color.
There's a spot color.
RICH MOORE: There's a
little bit of color.
So you're gonna want to
stay for some color--
RYAN GERMICK: The first
10 minutes.
RICH MOORE: --in "Wreck-It
Ralph."
RYAN GERMICK: So speaking of
color in "Wreck-It Ralph,"
let's talk about--
RICH MOORE: Trying to
sell it somehow.
RYAN GERMICK: It's in color!
It's an amazing film!
RICH MOORE: Guys, if you want to
see a movie in color, come
see this one.
We've got new colors.
We've got some colors you--
it's kind of purple, and
a little yellow.
RYAN GERMICK: So besides
the color,
there's an awesome cast.
All right.
We're going into "Wreck-It
Ralph" land now.
RICH MOORE: OK.
Got it.
RYAN GERMICK: All right.
The cast is amazing.
RICH MOORE: Yeah.
Very, very good.
RYAN GERMICK: They just
seem perfectly cast.
So you have Jack McBrayer, and
Sarah Silverman, and John C.
Reilly, and Jane Lynch
as the principles.
Can you just talk about what is
it like to, as a director,
harnessing the talent of these
terrific performers into their
cartoon avatars?
Like, what is that
experience like?
RICH MOORE: Well, it was
a terrific experience.
When Phil Johnston, who's the
screenwriter of the movie, and
I were developing the story for
"Wreck-It Ralph," Phil and
I have a similar
kind of method.
We really love the characters.
We like to start with the
characters, and really start
from the inside of the main
character and kind of build
out, rather than just starting
with the big world and then
kind of populating it.
So we were always really, really
conscious of who these
characters were, and who we
thought would be great to
portray them.
And a lot of times in animation,
sometimes the
characters will be created and
developed without any thought
going into, well, who
could play this?
But I'm a firm believer in,
there's the old saying that
good directing is 75%
good casting.
So we really wanted to play to
the strengths of our actors by
creating characters
that they felt
comfortable in their skin.
And Sarah Silverman was the
first one that really just
kind of presented itself clearly
in my mind, because we
knew we wanted to have this
world of Sugar Rush that was a
candy kart racing world,
game world.
But we wanted the character
from that world to be
seemingly innocent but
inappropriate at the same time.
And it was just like, a bell
went off, and Sarah's face was
in my head.
So that one was kind of
nailed very quickly.
And once we kind of landed on
who Ralph was as a character,
as a main character, it was very
easy to imagine John in
that role, because I'm
a huge fan of John's.
And to me, he can play a
character very funny and very,
very flawed.
But what's amazing about those
characters that he creates is
that I always care about them.
I always love those
characters.
And I want them to achieve their
goals and get what they
want, even if it's the character
in "Boogie Nights"
that wants to make
his bad record.
It's as wrongheaded
as anything, but I
want him to get that.
And that just speaks to John's
ability to just find the
humanity in every character
that he plays.
And I wanted that for Ralph.
RYAN GERMICK: Can I change
tracks for one second?
RICH MOORE: Sure.
RYAN GERMICK: So I'm wondering
about-- we talked a little
earlier, like before the show,
because we vacationed
together, and we had this--
no.
But I'm guessing you
were a kid who
loved to draw cartoons.
RICH MOORE: Yes.
RYAN GERMICK: And maybe a bit of
a smart aleck or something,
and you ended up doing like--
RICH MOORE: No.
RYAN GERMICK: No no no no.
Well, you don't know any
math, so something
happened there in school.
RICH MOORE: No math.
RYAN GERMICK: At what point
did you go from a kid who
loves to draw cartoons to being
someone who thinks about
caring about a character?
Because that transition seems
like a very adult, grown up
thing to transform as a
storyteller into, like, this
is funny to, like, this is
somebody that's going to be
emotionally impactful to me.
RICH MOORE: Right.
Well, I can't say exactly when
I realized that component of
storytelling.
But I think that that's
something, as filmmakers or
cartoonists or animators, that
that's something that they're
always striving for.
Because as we create these
characters, we create them to
tell stories.
And in order to do that, they
have to kind of reflect the
audience, in a way, or the
wishes of the audience, or
feelings and emotion that the
audience themselves have felt.
And that was something, going
back to "The Simpsons," I
would say that that's where I
learned it would be on "The
Simpsons" in those early days.
The goal wasn't just to
make a funny cartoon.
And Jim Brooks himself would
always say, look, guys, make
the fact that it's a
cartoon secondary.
We're not making a show that's
trying to show off the humor
of animation or cartooning.
We're making a sitcom, and it
happens to be animated.
That's where we sit
with this thing.
And with that information,
I knew what he meant.
Having watched a lot of sitcoms,
and watched a lot of
sitcoms that he had produced
and written, I knew exactly
what he meant.
And then it was learning
in practical terms
how to achieve that.
And for me, it was never losing
sight of the Simpsons
as a family.
That they were very
dysfunctional--
over the top dysfunctional.
But at the end of the day, it
was always my goal to depict
them as a family.
Like, this is the dad, the mom,
and the kids, and the
baby, and they love
one another.
And within this household, there
are situations that get
out of control.
But they are a family.
And I would kind of inject what
I knew of my family into
them and try to create
characters that would connect
with the rest of the world.
So I would say it was those
informative first years of
"The Simpsons" where that kind
of clicked in my mind.
RYAN GERMICK: I have some
of these images of the
development of Ralph.
Could you give us the director's
commentary of what
you think was going on at this
point, and how did it get to
the next level?
RICH MOORE: Well at this point,
there was a point in
the development, looking at this
picture right now, that
this would speak to kind of
the process of finding the
character--
who he is, what he looks
like, how he's going
to appear in animation.
And it was at this point that we
would depict Ralph a lot as
a beast or a monster or
sometimes an inanimate object.
He was a bulldozer at one time
with a face and everything.
We knew that he was something
that destroyed things, that he
was a wrecker.
And at the same time as this
drawing, or this painting, was
being produced and worked on,
a story team was working on
the story of the movie.
And in doing that, we were
discovering the main
relationship that Ralph
had in the movie
with another character.
And in filmmaking terms, or the
way that we think about
it, that main relationship
between our main character and
another one, between those two
lies the heart, as they call
the movie, of the story.
So at this point, we didn't know
that Ralph and Vanellope,
that their relationship
would be the main one.
And as the story kind of
dictated, well, Ralph is going
to become kind of this
big brother.
He starts out kind of like a
kid himself, because he's
selfish and kind of immature.
And he's going to meet this kid
who's got things way worse
than he does.
And he's going to kind of mature
into this kind of big
brother character
to Vanellope.
So as we start to kind of know
that about the story, we look
at this design, these ideas
for who Ralph is.
And this doesn't kind
of play into that.
When he was an ape or an animal
like this one, he
seemed more like a
big teddy bear or
something to a little kid.
He didn't seem like a big
brother type of character.
It seemed like Sully to Boo,
where she thought he was kind
of like a doll or something.
So at that point, once we knew
that the relationship between
Ralph and Vanellope was the main
one, and it was going to
be an immature guy kind of
becoming a parental figure to
this kid, then we started
to kind of refine.
And as you can see, it came
out just like this.
And then it became
more human--
someone that the kid
could relate to
him as like an adult.
And the two things kind of help
inform one another of
where the design and
the story goes.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
This is kind of where
we end up.
RICH MOORE: And there he is.
RYAN GERMICK: So I know a lot of
people at Google, or maybe
in the audience here, are
really excited about the
inclusion of the kind of pop
culture crossover of video
games in the movie.
My favorite crossover
is probably Qbert.
RICH MOORE: Yes.
Mine too, I would say.
RYAN GERMICK: There was
something about Qbert was
like, it scratched
an itch for me.
I don't know what that was.
Because he's kind of weird, and
he kind of hasn't really
made it into this generation.
But you still kind of
love him anyway.
RICH MOORE: No, but
he's out there.
And he's iconic, and just
mysterious enough that there
was never a lot of information
behind him, other than he was
jumping around on a pyramid
changing colors and things.
RYAN GERMICK: Was he swearing?
He had this weird language.
RICH MOORE: Was he swearing?
Was he talking?
And the supporting cast was kind
of cool, these weird tear
drop shaped guys, and
a coiled snake.
A very strange world.
But super appealing.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
Very appealing.
I saw some other interviews
that you did.
And people always try to-- it
was usually a lot of video
game outlets, and they'll be
like, so, are you a gamer?
And I've seen you sort
of struggle with the
question, to be honest.
RICH MOORE: Well, because it
means so many different things
to different people.
RYAN GERMICK: Totally, yeah.
RICH MOORE: It's like, I've
talked to some people like,
well, do you play Xbox Live?
It's like, well, no.
I'm making a movie, guys.
I don't have the time
to get on there.
And it's like, well then,
you're not a gamer
unless you do it.
So it seems like there's
lots of different
definitions for it.
But if it means am I someone
that as a kid played games and
followed them through the
different iterations of their
history, then yes.
And to be able to take a
character like Qbert, from my
childhood, and be able to put
it next to a character that
looks like he's right out of
Halo, to me is like, that's
better than any math.
That's better than solving
any math problem, to me.
RYAN GERMICK: There you go!
Take that!
So I thought I also heard you
mention something along the
lines of like, we're kind of at
the point where video games
are enough of a part of our
culture where there can be a
rich, universal story
told there.
And that might actually
be a new thing.
It might be only recently,
I think, maybe.
RICH MOORE: Well, I think
there's a good reason why this
movie got traction right now.
And I know at Disney, they were
trying to kind of crack
this one for 15 years, I think,
without success, up
until about four years ago when
we started to kind of
work on this iteration of it.
And it may speak more to
culturally people being ready
to hear a story like this,
with video games as the
backdrop of the story, than they
were maybe 10 years ago.
I think "Roger Rabbit" came out
right at the right time
for that kind of movie, where
those types of animation had
been around long enough that
children knew what it was, and
very old people knew
what it was.
And I think we may be at that
point with video games, where
the timing's appropriate.
Like, it knew when it wanted
to be made, I think.
RYAN GERMICK: I think the "Roger
Rabbit" of video games
is pretty apt, in many ways.
RICH MOORE: That's pretty cool,
because I really loved
that movie.
RYAN GERMICK: It's a
great movie, yeah.
I think it lives
up to it, too.
RICH MOORE: And that's another
one that right around the same
time that I was working on
"Mighty Mouse." And Disney
Studios was beginning to kind
of launch into their second
Golden Age, as they call it,
with "Little Mermaid." "Roger
Rabbit" came out also.
So there was like an explosion
of animation going on.
It was a right around the time
that John Lasseter and Ed
Campbell were beginning to
kind of roll with Pixar.
So to have this called the
"Roger Rabbit" of video games
is quite an honor.
RYAN GERMICK: Deserved.
RICH MOORE: Thank you.
RYAN GERMICK: So this is
actually the game in the
movie, "Wreck-It Ralph." And
there's an interesting divide
in the movie, I think, between
these types of like, Donkey
Kong, Pac-Man, sort of more
friendly, accessible games, to
the kind of horror world that
Ralph finds himself.
RICH MOORE: Of Hero's Duty.
RYAN GERMICK: Of Hero's Duty.
I thought that was a really apt
commentary, because I'm
someone who feels left behind
in the ultra violent, ultra
realistic, murky world.
RICH MOORE: Right, the
horrific video games.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
Does that resonate with you?
Or what kind of commentary--
were you trying to make
commentary there?
Was it--
RICH MOORE: Well, I mean, it
was something that started
more as a joke.
And it's like any kind of thing,
as people start to
inject a point of view to it, it
becomes kind of commentary.
And I think it began as just,
like, what would Donkey Kong
think if he was thrown
into Halo?
RYAN GERMICK: Right.
That would be an awesome
game, actually.
RICH MOORE: Yeah.
And it became just kind of
like, his thought on it.
But it is interesting.
Why weren't the games
ultra-violent
like that back then?
Is it just because we need a
bigger rush, or we're callous
to the old ones?
I don't know.
But and when you think about
it, what I like about it is
that it does give pause to kind
of reflect on something
like that, because do people
realize, like, oh my god,
yeah, they are pretty violent.
I would hate to make them not
violent, because I think there
is a reason and a need for
that type of thing.
But it is interesting.
And I find it is very
interesting that over the
course of 30 years,
these things have
become very, very graphic.
And I think if it opens up a
discussion, then I think
that's good.
RYAN GERMICK: So another one of
the games that they enter
in the movie is Sugar Rush,
which is kind of like a Mario
Kart racer game.
RICH MOORE: And Candy Land kind
of all mixed together.
RYAN GERMICK: So here's
something I thought was
interesting in the film was that
all of the other games,
like the Hero's Quest and the
sort of Wreck-It Ralph," they
have real life analogs.
RICH MOORE: Right.
RYAN GERMICK: But I wonder, this
is like the ultra girly,
sort of clearly marketed towards
women video games--
those don't really exist.
Has the industry failed women?
Or is that just a stupid
stereotype that shouldn't be
pursued anyway?
RICH MOORE: Well, with Sugar
Rush, we were trying to play
more like it was for children.
If Hero's Duty was more adult
and graphic and more for men,
that this was for
little children.
But as to have women been left
behind, I don't know.
I guess like, it doesn't
seem like--
all I know is that my daughter,
let's say that this
was your favorite
type of game.
Like Mario Kart, that was one.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
My sister destroys
me in Mario Kart.
RICH MOORE: Yeah.
The day that my daughter beat
me in Mario Kart was the day
that I knew I should
hang it up.
But I didn't.
So I just go by what I know,
and that was always a game
that in my house was popular not
just for my daughter, but
my son, too.
So it was more kind of trying to
depict something like that,
just to give the contrast of
these two worlds and Ralph's
journey of going from one that's
like this, and violent,
and going to very
kid friendly.
But also, it's the point in the
story where what I like
about it is it's this very
saccharine sweet type of
place, but holds kind of the
most nefarious secret of the
story in it.
RYAN GERMICK: No spoilers.
RICH MOORE: No.
RYAN GERMICK: So talking
a bit about the story.
You know "Save the Cat!"
RICH MOORE: Right.
RYAN GERMICK: I have to totally
call you on this.
Like, when Qbert gets the
cherry, that's a total "Save
the Cat!" moment.
RICH MOORE: It kind
of is, yeah.
It kind of is.
RYAN GERMICK: That's cool.
RICH MOORE: But it's cool.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah, it works.
It totally works.
RICH MOORE: And that book
does float around at
our studio a lot.
Some people, that's their
Bible, and some people,
"Robert McKee's Story"
is their Bible.
RYAN GERMICK: For anybody who
doesn't know, and I've never
this book, and I'm a total hack
in most things in life,
including knowing
story structure.
RICH MOORE: Well, it comes
from-- do you know what movie
it comes from?
RYAN GERMICK: No, I
don't, actually.
RICH MOORE: Um, neither do I,
off the top of my head.
RYAN GERMICK: "Home Alone
3," I'm pretty sure.
RICH MOORE: But the one that
they always cite is "Sea of
Love," with Al Pacino,
where he's playing
this undercover cop.
The movie begins with all these
dads coming in with
their sons, thinking that
they're going to get free
tickets to a baseball game.
And it turns out the whole thing
is a sting operation,
that all these dads are
criminals, and it's been set
up by Al Pacino.
RYAN GERMICK: Who seems
like a bad guy.
RICH MOORE: Yeah, who seems
like, oh, that's cold, man.
And so as he's leaving the
sting, they're locking all
these guys up.
Actually, no.
The guys are coming in
without their sons.
It's just a bunch of guys coming
in to get free tickets.
And then as Pacino's leaving, in
the hallway, the last crook
is kind of coming in.
He's late, and he's brought his
son with him-- this little
kid-- and says, am I too late
for the free tickets?
And Pacino, seeing this, he
doesn't want the kid to see
his dad get cuffed.
He's like, no, we're all out.
You missed it, man.
Maybe next time.
And the guy gets to
go away free.
But we feel like Pacino's got
a heart, that he's not just
the tough, mean cop, that he
cares about this guy's kid
seeing him get locked up.
So that's where it comes from.
And it is kind of one
of those moments.
RYAN GERMICK: Can I spoil
one thing in the movie?
Is that OK?
RICH MOORE: Sure.
The whole ending.
RYAN GERMICK: Can I whisper it
into your ear what it is?
RICH MOORE: I think that's OK.
RYAN GERMICK: OK.
So I like the character
arc of a story.
Close your ears if you don't
want to hear this.
It's an extremely minor
plot point.
RICH MOORE: It's minor.
RYAN GERMICK: I love the way
that this develops characters
and the way that characters
have an arc in this film.
It's a really good movie.
I really enjoyed it.
RICH MOORE: Thank you.
RYAN GERMICK: But the one thing
is that you can't leave
this movie saying that the main
character didn't change,
because in the beginning, he
doesn't like chocolate, and in
the end, he likes chocolate.
So at least you have that.
RICH MOORE: That's not the one
you just whispered to me.
You just ruined the whole
movie for these people.
I thought we were friends.
I thought I could trust you.
You invite me to Google.
We're joking, guys.
RYAN GERMICK: There's
a million clever
things in the movie.
So a couple here-- like,
do you want to
talk about Grand Central--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH MOORE: Game Central
Station.
RYAN GERMICK: All right.
Bring it on.
RICH MOORE: Well, once we made
the decision to set the whole
thing in an arcade, we knew we
wanted the characters to be
able to visit one another in
the different cabinets.
So as Phil Johnston and I were
trying to kind of crack like,
well, how are they going to
go from game to game?
And the process that we use is
we just kind of throw out any
idea, like how about this?
Where we weren't afraid
to say anything dumb.
And there was a good
two weeks where we
thought, OK, this is it.
The device that they're going to
use to travel from game to
game is that in a toilet,
there is a vortex.
And for at least two weeks,
we thought this is
in the final movie.
This is so good.
It means nothing.
I mean, it has nothing to
do with video games.
It has nothing to do
with anything.
But at that point in developing
the story, we
thought it was great.
And then two weeks go by, and we
thought, the toilet vortex
thing is not so good.
And Phil was living in
Brooklyn at the time.
And I was flying out there
a lot to New York
to work with him.
And this is one of those
stories that you
go, oh, come on.
Please.
But Phil was going back to
Brooklyn, I was in Manhattan,
staying in a hotel, and
we walked over to
Grand Central Station.
I was walking him
to his train.
And it was like, man, I think
it should just be like this.
It should just be like this.
It should just be like a big
Grand Central Station, but
it's in the power strip
or something.
And these trains, these are
the plugs, you know?
These are the plugs.
And I was like, yeah.
And it would be like Game
Central Station, right?
And he was like, yeah.
It could just be something
simple like that.
And we were like, are we having
an idea right now?
RYAN GERMICK: Did you
hug or something?
RICH MOORE: No, it was just kind
of, we got very quiet,
and kind of like an animal gets
kind of bristly after
it's done what it's built to
do, where it's that kind of
like gorillas or something.
And it was like, looking at one
another and thinking, I
think something just
happened here.
And we agreed, OK, before we
decide anything, let's sleep
on it and see what we think
in the morning.
And we both as soon as we got
up, texted each other, I
really like that Game Central
Station idea.
And that's what it was
kind of born from.
So if you're ever trying to
figure something out, I
recommend going to New York, go
to Grand Central Station,
walk around with your friend.
RYAN GERMICK: I'll do it.
RICH MOORE: It comes
like that.
RYAN GERMICK: Well, like animals
that have finished
building what they came
out to build--
RICH MOORE: Animals don't
build-- well, beavers do.
RYAN GERMICK: Beavers do.
RICH MOORE: They do.
You're right.
RYAN GERMICK: Ants.
Bees.
RICH MOORE: They
do, all right.
Yeah, they build.
RYAN GERMICK: Termites.
RICH MOORE: Yeah.
RYAN GERMICK: So if there are
any audience questions,
there's a microphone phone
around that Chris has.
And he will pass it around.
AUDIENCE: How do you, from
a director's role--
RICH MOORE: This is going
to be a hard one.
I can tell.
I can already tell this is going
to go for the throat.
RYAN GERMICK: It's gonna
be a math question.
AUDIENCE: It's gonna
2 plus 2 equals window.
RICH MOORE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So my question to
you is, how do you as a
director keep your
team motivated,
especially your artists?
Since it's such a
long endeavor.
RICH MOORE: That's
a good question.
Well, it is a long endeavor.
And we worked for four
years on this movie.
And sometimes animated films
can go on for eight years.
There's some that have gone on
for 10 years in development
and production.
And what's interesting is,
too, it's a very non
spontaneous process.
And my job is to, by the end,
make the whole experience,
what the audience is seeing,
feel as if they're watching it
kind of happen right before
their eyes as if it was live
action captured on film.
So I would say the way that I
kind of keep that exciting or
spontaneous is just we challenge
each other in making
the artwork or the performance
the best it can be.
I think that I work with a group
of people that really
want the best out of everything
that they do.
So they're looking to
me for guidance on
this kind of thing.
What keeps it interesting and
satisfying for the artists and
myself is that I remind
myself I'm a director.
I'm not a dictator.
I'm not there to dictate to
someone, no, do it like this.
I want it yellow.
And I want it like this,
and I want-- you know.
My job is to kind of bring out
what this person can bring to
the idea, not tell them.
To me, they're not
just a wrist.
And that's where the best of
someone comes-- the best of an
artist or technician or
production person
working on the movie.
So I always try to encourage the
crew to take ownership of
what they're doing,
to not look to me
for the final answer.
Like, I'm not going to tell
you exactly how to do it.
I want you to discover it,
because you are going to bring
something to it that I'm
not thinking of.
Your point of view is going
to make it better.
So I try not to dictate.
I try not to tell people exactly
how they should do it,
because to me, there's
no fun in that.
It's not fun for me, it's
not fun for the artist.
The fun is to kind of watch the
thing grow as different
minds are kind of put onto it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I was delighted by the way
you captured the essence of
the '80s era video games like
Donkey Kong and Rampage and
Elevator Action in the
Wreck-It Ralph game.
RICH MOORE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious, what was
your creative process for
imagining that game?
And what was the technical
process for
developing the visuals?
RICH MOORE: The actual game?
What we did is--
and that was one of the first
things that we kind of dove
into was the actual gameplay, or
just concept of that world,
what it was about.
And the process was working with
the story crew and the
design crew of just kind
of creating boards.
First, putting up images of
games that we thought that
this was like.
It's kind of like Donkey Kong.
It's kind of like Rampage.
And then breaking down, like,
what made those games unique?
How much detail did
they have to them?
What were the goals?
And what made them appealing?
And then beginning a lot of
visual just boards of
different people's ideas of what
can the gameplay be like,
starting with this idea of one
guy fixes, one guy wrecks.
And it was months and
months and months.
It did not happen overnight.
It was a lot of experimentation,
and a lot of
going back to those old games.
Because I found, for me, it
was one thing to kind of
remember them fondly and have
nostalgic feelings for them.
But to go back and then just
see them again with a more
critical eye and more kind
of study them was a whole
different kind of experience
altogether for myself.
So it was a lot of
trial and error.
It was a lot of trying different
things and trying to
kind of capture the kind of
off-beat nature of them.
They're kind of funky
in their concepts.
And that's where the idea of
fixing a broken window with a
hammer came from, because it
just doesn't make any sense.
But it seemed like, well, but
that seems like what they
would have had in one
of those old games.
So we never let logic ruin
of the good ideas.
And again, it was a lot
of trial and error.
It was a lot of going
back and forth.
And then we tried designing kind
of a very crude version
of the game, what the graphics
would look like.
And I think we did
that in Flash.
And as we got further into
production, we knew we wanted
to build an actual cabinet
with the game
in it that was playable.
And for that, we went to someone
who programmed games
back in that time period.
And he used the 8-bit boards.
And there's a CRT in it.
We wanted it to be as authentic
as it could be.
And because of making that one
game, the studio realized,
well, this would be great.
People would love this if we
built a bunch of these things
and took them around the
country, put them in theaters,
and at old arcades
that still exist.
So the first one that we built
was made out of a gutted--
it was a Donkey Kong game.
So the studio was saying,
we would love 50
to 60 of these things.
So not wanting to be the studio
that put 50 Donkey Kong
cabinets out of commission, we
decided, well, we're going to
build them from the ground up.
So I think a couple were here.
Did they bring some over?
RYAN GERMICK: Nobody let
me play anything.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RICH MOORE: Oh, Google,
I am sorry.
I feel like a jerk now.
RYAN GERMICK: Thanks a lot.
Movies in color, everybody.
That's it.
RICH MOORE: Why?
Why?
But they did a great job
of weathering them.
They really feel like they're
30 years old, and they play
very much like those
old games.
I'm really proud of them.
And it happened kind of right
in tandem with the movie.
So we made a movie and a game.
Ha!
Pretty good, huh?
RYAN GERMICK: Not too bad.
AUDIENCE: All right.
So in seeing you with your
classmates and hearing you
talk about them and that
experience, I realized you
must have been there at the same
time that my roommate's
grandfather was teaching.
And I was wondering if you could
say something about the
teachers, and specifically
if you--
RICH MOORE: Wow, that
makes me feel--
AUDIENCE: Uh, Bob McCrea.
RICH MOORE: My father's Daddy
Pop's uncle was there.
About the teachers that
were at CalArts?
Who was--
AUDIENCE: Um, Bob McCrea.
RICH MOORE: Oh, Bob McCrea was
the director of the program at
the time, and he was a
wonderful teacher.
He was someone that worked at
Disney during the golden age
of animation, and he was kind
of a father figure to us.
And he had, let's see.
Hal Ambro was our animation
teacher.
Our design teacher
was Bob Winquist.
And Bob Winquest took over for
Bob McCrae, because he became
ill during our--
he was very old--
during our sophomore year, and
Bob became the director of the
department our junior year.
And I really, really
loved Bob Winquist.
Not only was he a great designer
and a great design
teacher, but he had a way of
talking to us in our class.
He was very nurturing.
He really knew how to kind of
bring out the best in people.
People in our class who did
not consider themselves
designers, by the end of his
classes really felt like, wow,
I never knew I could
design something.
I didn't know I had
this in me.
So he was just someone that
really fostered feeling in us
that we could do something
in animation.
We had one teacher in particular
who felt it was his
job to teach us another
vocation, because he said we
would never make it in
animation, that animation was
a dying business, and it
was going nowhere.
So we really knew
how to paint.
We would have to know how to
paint paintings to be Denny's
menus covers.
And he thought he
was helping us.
But Bob Winquist really
instilled in us this feeling
that if enough people with a
passion for something were to
go out in the world, that
you could change it.
And that you could bring back
an art form that seemed at
that time to be--
there's nothing going on.
It was dead.
And I credit him a lot for
awakening up our ability to
have vision for the
future, and our
careers, and our lives.
And I miss him a lot.
He passed away three
years ago.
And he was a wonderful guy.
And so many people credit him as
just an instrumental figure
at that school at the time.
RYAN GERMICK: Do we have time
for one more question?
This man came all the way
from Los Angeles.
RICH MOORE: All the
way from LA.
RYAN GERMICK: The land of video
game arcades that we'll
never be able to play.
One more?
In the middle over here?
AUDIENCE: So one thing that's
really interesting to me is
you talk a lot about how Ralph
had go back and be redesigned
several times.
And the game had to go back
and be redesigned.
And like, every element it seems
like you chose like 30
different things before you
finally decided on one.
Have you ever reached
a point where--
RICH MOORE: I'm indecisive.
I'm wishy washy.
RYAN GERMICK: I'm not gonna
tell you what to do.
It's just gonna--
RICH MOORE: You know what,
he flip-flops.
He's a waffler.
AUDIENCE: So it seems to me like
a movie is a very-- like,
a really great movie--
RICH MOORE: I thought we were
gonna have a debate.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah,
more conflict.
AUDIENCE: So my question
basically stems from the fact
that a great movie seems to be
a very delicate balance of a
lot of things.
And in being so indecisive
you find that balance.
But have you ever gotten maybe
halfway through making a movie
before realizing your entire
premise was wrong, and either
giving up or starting
over on everything?
RICH MOORE: Well, that has not
happened to me, personally.
But I know some people that
that has happened to.
So it does exist.
It does exist.
Or they won't give up
on the whole thing.
But they will try to take
elements of something that's
not working and reimagine
it as something else.
And I think that having
that ability to
do that at a studio--
and it sounds scary.
And it sounds like it's
a horrible thing.
But some really good movies have
come out of moments like
that, where they were going in
one direction and turned into
something else.
And movies at Pixar, things
like that have happened.
And I think it speaks a lot to
the management of the studios,
like Pixar and like Disney, that
are willing to give the
artist and the directors the
room to make mistakes and to
try different things and to
really take a stab at
something and gamble.
And if it didn't work,
then it didn't work.
So now let's try something
that did work.
And that's what we always tried
to do on this movie was
to be wrong quickly.
Let's just throw it out there
and see if it works.
And if it doesn't, OK.
We know what we're
shooting for.
We knew early on in this movie
who our characters were, when
Phil and I were designing the
characters and putting
together the cast.
So we knew from a very early
point in the development of
the film who those
characters were.
And the story changed
quite a few times.
We knew exactly what we wanted
to happen to Ralph at the end,
so the mechanics of
the thing changed.
And we got there, to the one
that we have now, the final
one, by trying lots of
different things.
And it doesn't just happen
like that overnight.
It takes time to kind of let
these things percolate.
And the whole thing has an
organic feeling to it.
It grows at its own
pace, I believe.
I think things will happen
when they want to happen.
Things will be solved when
they need to be solved.
And for me, it's just being
patient enough to
kind of let it happen.
AUDIENCE: So one quick
follow up.
I kind of have a theory that a
lot of the really great shorts
come from movies that just
couldn't be fished out as long
as they wanted to.
Do you know if any of those were
just made from elements
of a failed path?
RICH MOORE: What, like
the Pixar shorts?
Or shorts like the
classic shorts?
Or just shorts in general?
AUDIENCE: Whatever
you know about?
RICH MOORE: No, I think a lot
of the shorts that you see
before a Pixar movie
or a Disney movie
did begin as a short.
They were imagined as shorts.
I can't think of one off the top
of my head that began as
something more than a short.
And usually, they've began as
avenues for a new director to
try his hands at directing or
getting his feet wet in
something a little
more manageable
than a feature film.
I can't really think
of something that--
it's a good theory.
I credit you on that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
RICH MOORE: It's astute.
But I don't have any evidence
to back up your theory.
RYAN GERMICK: Rich Moore,
thank you so much
for coming to Google.
RICH MOORE: Thank you.
Thank you.
RYAN GERMICK: It was
truly a pleasure.
RICH MOORE: Thank you, Google.
It's a real pleasure.
RYAN GERMICK: The movie
is "Wreck-It Ralph.
It's in theaters November
2nd, and it's in color.
Check it out.
RICH MOORE: In color.
Glorious color.
Thank you very much, everybody.